[Music]
good morning hey thang look what the
librarians in Baltimore did it's Monday
May 14 Hank your video and Friday
prompted an intense discussion in the
comments section of brotherhood to calm
the specific question at hand whether or
not the nerdfighter should build a time
machine and go back in time and kill
baby Hitler Hank when it comes to baby
Hitler killing people tend to fall into
one of two camps the first camp says we
shouldn't kill the baby Hitler he's just
a baby
he's not even evil yet he hasn't killed
anyone the other camp of people say are
you crazy
what the hell are you talking about we
need to go back in time and kill baby
Hitler I tend to side with those people
I have to say Hank there's just
something about killing the baby Hitler
that appeals to me Hank it seemed that
the two camps probaby Hitler killing an
anti baby killer killing would never be
able to reconcile and that there would
be a split among the nerdfighters that
could possibly lead to a nerdfighter
Civil War but then Along Came commenter
Brook who suggested the evil baby
orphanage oh my god Hank the evil baby
orphanage is such a good idea I don't
understand how no one thought of it
before the idea is simple we go back in
time and we don't kill all the evil
babies we just take them out of their
crappy homes and then we take them to
like a mountain and to bed or something
where we raise them up to be heroic
nerdfighter babies Hank something has to
be done to this evil baby orphanage idea
but I don't know what to do with it
hopefully you or someone else will have
good ideas in other news Hank I would
like to read to you from a deleted
portion of the Wikipedia entry for an
abundance of katherines the novel starts
with James Lloyd a nun charismatic young
actor who is considering leaving behind
his career in London and moving to
America by moving he also hopes to leave
behind Catherine a girl he has long had
feelings for but who repeatedly turned
him down while his career grows in
strength he begins to cautiously
experiment in homosexuality with some of
the other cast members of the film he is
working on Hank ah that sounds like a
fairly good book but it doesn't sound
like the book I wrote Hank after I
discovered this entirely fictional and
extremely odd plot summary of an
abundance of katherines I started to
look around Wikipedia for more
information about you
and about me and you know what I found
not much in fact tank the entry in the
only girl 15 Wikipedia about me is more
informative in many ways than the entry
in the actual Wikipedia but you know
it's even worse than the fictional
Wikipedia entry about an abundance of
katherines the fact that there is no
entry whatsoever about Hank green can
you believe it
Wikipedia has never even tried to fathom
the inky blue deaths of Hank Green's
genius Hank that is not acceptable and
with the help of the nerdfighters I'm
gonna do something about it we're making
you a Wikipedia entry because you've
earned it big guy
and hopefully also some people will
improve the entries for me and for
Looking for Alaska and for an abundance
of katherines that's what Wikipedia is
all about it's about brothers creating
Wikipedia entries for brothers right
isn't that what it's about Hank I'll see
you tomorrow
PS Hank I don't know if you realize this
but in the last week we've raised more
than three hundred dollars for Randy's
family and we'll be collecting donations
all this week